it's like what is shrek and that's
that's a pretty straightforward question
like he's an ogre he lives in a swamp he
doesn't have any friends so he's he's
not much different from you roughly
speaking and
and shrek 2 which is a very old story he
has to go off to far far away to meet
his new in-laws it's like you may think
meeting in-laws is a cakewalk man but it
is not especially if you're an ogre and
so what does shrek do well he brings his
friend donkey and why is that
why is it that he's always hanging
around with a donkey well because when
you're an ogre who spends all of your
time in the swamp your only friend is
going to be an ass
[Music]
welcome to episode 117 of the michaela
peterson podcast in this episode i had
sheamus the creator of freedom tunes on
the podcast with my dad
i hope you guys enjoy it i've had a lot
of personal changes you could say in the
last few months
my dad's healthier than he has been in
maybe five years my mom is healthy i'm
healthy
i just moved to franklin which is south
of nashville last week rather abruptly
andre's moving too scarlet's coming up
and i've set up her room with everything
pink it's been an insane few months
slash 29 years really i'll do a q a soon
to update everyone but things are going
really really well
in this episode i went into a bit of a
description about finding god for god
finding me
i'll get into that more in my q a
because it's been pretty intense
it's something i've been searching for
for a few years and recently it clicked
more about that later though as you can
see i'm recording on my phone because
i'm going on blaze tv tomorrow and i
don't have my studio set up yet in
franklin it should be set up next
episode
in this episode we covered sheamus
catholic roots
his creation of freedom tunes and
there's a great amount of sheamus
imitating my dad which i at least found
incredibly entertaining i hope you guys
enjoy this episode
[Music]
seamus welcome to the podcast thank you
so much for having me it's much
appreciated
i surprised you with my dad you did
we were working on technical
difficulties so i didn't have too much
of a a chance to fanboy over it's great
to uh meet you doctor
thank you is it you that does those
horrible
imitations of my voice i wouldn't say
horrible i'm the one who does the really
good ones
yeah yeah they're appalling they're
appallingly good and thank you i'm glad
you think so
yeah yeah very amusing
i'm really i'm actually very happy to
hear that and i think
one mark of a person's level of humility
is their sense of humor about themselves
and so it's been fantastic the way that
you've reacted to them and shared them
around not only because it gives me
publicity but i think it reflects very
well on you that you've been so cool
about it
yeah well there's much worse things than
having comedians think that you're
interesting enough to parody you i mean
i don't see how you can take offense to
that it's like what do you want to be
ignored in some hole in the corner
i can see sometimes how that might be
okay too though yeah
exactly see this was exactly why i
became a cartoonist to do political
commentary no one has to see my face
i've outed myself now but
okay so before before we get into
conversation sheamus i think you should
give a brief background about who you
are and what you do to anybody who isn't
familiar with your work i started
cartooning when i was really pretty
young i mean i was
that kid who was drawing and doodling in
class rather than paying attention which
is evident based on my level of
intelligence and the things i say in my
work people go these cartoons are great
but if only this kid had paid attention
in school um
i
started teaching myself to animate when
i was about 13 years old
using a very old software
and i just kept advancing with it when i
was 14.
i took on my first freelance gigs
uh which paid you know pennies
but i was excited to be working in my
field and so
by the time i finished high school
i knew i wanted to start a business in
animation production
and the demand for animators had risen
something like 30 that year and i
thought all right this is a good time to
try it and what people don't know about
the animation industry
is it isn't just disney in fact it isn't
even just cartoons like i do
a lot of it is just designing graphics
or
doing uh motion logos for people that
kind of thing and so i thought that when
i started i was mostly going to be doing
that stuff
but as it would happen i found this
conservative organization
that wanted to hire me
to do these short little cartoons and it
was this this small little website that
a friend ran basically
and so they asked me would you like to
make some cartoons for us
and we'll put them on our website
and there wasn't really much success
with them
but they enjoyed that i was making them
so i think we maybe did three episodes
and at the time i was extremely
libertarian i'm much more conservative
now but
problems sort of began to arise because
they their website merged
with
a larger conservative organization and i
never really ended up doing anything for
them because when we started
they would kind of give me notes on
things and i also had this feeling that
i might end up having to promote things
that i personally didn't believe in at
the time
so i thought
i'm just gonna start uploading these
cartoons to my youtube channel just
start making my own stuff that no one is
giving me notes on
and that i get to engineer all by myself
and i'll put them on my channel and
we'll see what happens and so i started
doing that and
it gained traction over time and
eventually took off to to being what it
is today and a lot of that was grinding
and being consistent with the release
schedule and a lot of that was just also
prayer uh and providence
and i've got a story about that i'd like
to get into in a little bit just about
the intervention of of saint joseph and
the role i believe that's played in my
career
so that's where this disgusting goes
completely off the rails
exactly
come on
dr peterson are you capable of a
discussion that doesn't go completely
off the rails ah
that's a good question on many levels of
analysis believe me so how successful is
freedom tunes now
that's a really good question
so
in terms of the raw numbers
the channel has we're approaching 700
000 subscribers
i have
probably about three people who work
with me as animators pretty regularly
and we're going to be bringing more on
i've also branched out and i service
other organizations that i think could
use animation and whose message i want
to promote
and so it's it's expanded into a small
business and animation production
generally which is great because what i
wanted from the start was to be able to
serve these underrepresented communities
within entertainment i knew that
conservatives and catholics
weren't really getting so it's pretty
politically correct to be serving under
reproduction i know exactly that's how i
put it so doctor i went to art school i
had to find ways to couch these things
when my professors asked what my
aspirations were that wouldn't get me
thrown out and so
i'm just saying you know there's some
groups that are all that well
represented in media
and part of the problem is conservatives
generally haven't been that great at
producing entertaining media
and i've gotten into some of the reasons
for that i think it often
i think the problem is conservatives
will put too much emphasis on the
message and not enough on just making it
entertaining
and the reality is
if you make something entertaining by
virtue of the fact that you wrote it and
you have your values your values are
going to come through and they're going
to be promoted in some way but i think a
lot of people don't realize that and so
their work is unsubtle
and it failed and so i just knew that i
wanted to work like i said with just
catholic and generally conservative
organizations
and to promote good values and help
fight in the culture war in some small
way
yeah it's a strange situation when
conservatives start to develop a sense
of humor
it is you know the world's turning
upside down
that's what so here's the thing i think
we've generally had a pretty good sense
of humor that people haven't recognized
because for years and years the
conservatives were the butt of every
joke on television and conservatives
were still watching and laughing at it
even when they were the ones getting
ripped on
well i would even argue that people who
are conservatives right now aren't
really that conservative that's also
very true that's very true we might have
just switched into the people who were
funny right if you think about liberals
and then in the 60s like i feel like
most conservatives are way closer to
that or even maybe even 70s i'm not sure
no it it that that's a really
interesting point uh it's difficult to
define the right and i've said this in
the past the way that i define the left
is essentially is acting against the
catholic church and her values because
we see the inception of the left at the
french revolution
and their goals were very plainly stated
they were acting against virtually
everything that i believe is is good in
the world and conservatives
don't necessarily exist as a force for
the church but they exist as a force
against the left and it can become
difficult to define what that means
because the left takes different shapes
and forms in terms of the ideas that it
wants to promote in any given era what's
fashionable among them
changes very frequently and so
conservatives because they define
themselves in opposition to the left as
opposed to having their own core values
that they understand well
aren't really a well-defined group
unfortunately it's something like at
this point conservatives are just a
group of people with vaguely similar
views about the economy i think and
a wide variety
of social perspectives
and in some ways it's good to have a
large tent
but the lines can't become so blurred
that nothing means anything anymore and
i think that is something which has kind
of happened in the conservative movement
i'm curious about uh
your conservative beliefs and the
relationship between that and your
catholicism and why you're attracted to
catholicism i mean you're a young man
and so you're kind of a rare bird well
you're probably the only one like you a
conservative catholic young animator
do you so you'd be surprised there are
more of us than you think but we lurk in
the shadows
i believe that so i was raised gathered
if you can't tell from the hopelessly
ethnic name uh i'm from an irish
catholic family
and i was raised right outside of
chicago
and my entire extended family lived in
the inner city and it was very large a
very large family and so we would get
together for family gatherings a lot and
they were almost always
they almost always revolved around the
church in some way
and so it was culturally instilled in me
but more importantly my parents were
true believers
and they did what they could to ensure
that i would be a true believer as well
now unfortunately at some point the
world gets its claws on you
and in my teens
i would say i very much fell away from
my face
and
i believe in my very late teens like
when i was 19
i maybe even told my brother
at some point that i was functionally an
atheist
i was kind of going through the motions
i didn't really accept it in my heart
and at the time i thought that it's
because i was reading all of these good
arguments for atheism but in retrospect
a lot of it was a desire i think on a
subconscious level to justify the life
that i was living because as it is said
you either live what you believe or
believe what you live
and i was sort of going to church as
fire insurance
but
i don't know that i in fact i do know
that i didn't really hold the values in
my heart because i would just sin and
then i would tell myself you know i can
go to confession i'll be forgiven it's
fine i would continually presume upon
god's mercy
and when you don't respect god
inevitably you stop believing in him and
so
when i was about 20 i won't get too into
detail but i had an experience that was
traumatic for me
and that's when it clicked
that bad things can happen to me which
is something that many young men don't
realize and i certainly didn't
and then you put it together that well a
bad thing can happen to me and if bad
things can happen to me because i'm made
of the same stuff everyone else is
then the worst possible thing could
happen to me i could end up in hell for
all of eternity
and that's when i really began to
seriously consider that
and also when i was in the midst of this
frightening situation i genuinely
believe the blessed virgin was there for
me
so
at this point i really started what is
that sorry
can you pause for a second i'm not uh
i'm not super familiar i mean my dad is
my dad but i'm not super familiar with
the intricacies of of religion or
catholicism so when you said you
believed the blessed virgin was there
for you what does that mean
so
i'm trying i don't want to get too much
into detail about the specifics of the
circumstance but
my brother was there with me
and he started praying a hail mary
prayer
and
you could say that in large part it
solved the problem
i wish i could be more detailed than
that
interesting
[Music]
that's very interesting i had i can talk
about this because i haven't talked
about it before but i grew up with
dad so we i learned a lot about the like
psychological significance of the bible
the youtube series on um
and it was always
kind of through that lens like metaphors
uh and then i had
i had like way too many really absurd
experiences
that i couldn't wrap my head around
where i was like
my life doesn't make any this doesn't
make any sense this doesn't make any
sense this is too weird like too
coincidental
and that happened for like five years
like every day
and uh i had and then some like rough
had some rough experiences over the
summer
and about a month ago
i would say i think i think i can say
this i would say i found god
which i have which i haven't before like
i didn't i definitely haven't before and
it was very sudden and it was
when i was
um
anyway
what i've been doing for the last i'm
pretty new to this and what i've been
doing for the last like month or so is
reading the bible and praying
and i guess in a way that's more like
protestant probably
uh and it's been
the like amount of peace that i've had
i haven't had before yeah it's
completely absurd i can't believe it
like
so
i was looking forward to talking to you
because my mom practices catholicism and
i haven't really understood it very well
because i felt like part of it was
kind of
i don't want to say vindictive but i
felt like there was a punishing element
to it so that if you do something wrong
it's like you know repent and kind of
punish yourself and i feel like
with my type of brain i do and i have
enough guilt in me that i punish myself
enough for anything i meet maybe even
don't even do that wrong so i was like i
wasn't very attracted to the whole
catholicism thing because i thought
there was a punishment element
so i was interested in talking to you to
like learn a little bit more about it
yeah um i certainly i have some thoughts
on the punishment element but was i'm
curious can i ask about your experience
first
yeah uh what would so when you said you
felt you discovered god
what was that was it just like in a
single moment you realize that things
just lined up too well or
uh it was like i had this one day where
i was worrying about a a number there
were like four really important and i'm
not going to get into details it's fine
either like you did but like
really i get it four really important
parts of my life that and all of them
were going really badly like in ways
where i was like what am i am i not
trying hard enough like what more can i
do i can't do more to fix these four
major problems
and then
i met somebody
i was going to check out austin to see
if i wanted to stay in austin for the
winter which i don't but
i met somebody there and he's christian
and he was like well how are you
managing with all these problems and i
was like i'm not managing well i'm
really not managing well like i'm
working and i'm keeping it together but
i don't feel good
uh and i used to be like clinically
depressed and i
and i wasn't depression i just wasn't
feeling good and he was like well that's
why you need god and i said okay well
that's fine and dandy you know it's nice
when somebody comes up to you and is
like well you need god
because that's how are you supposed to
wrap your head around that so i was like
well i don't know like yeah okay maybe
that sounds great but i don't know how
to get there
uh and he said just beg for him to
reveal himself to you like ask him to
that's what he said ask him to reveal
himself to you and so i went home that
night and i was and i was pretty upset
about like these four major problems
and i was in bed so i was praying like
seriously praying like please
give me some sort of sign please reveal
himself to you and the next day
all four problems cleared up in ways
that
i like made sense it was a lot like they
could have cleared up but the likelihood
of all four of them clearing up randomly
that day was just too much so that
happened and i also woke up with this
sense of calm i hadn't felt like the
sense of calm right here
and that was enough
i was like okay that's good that's good
enough for me so it was kind of like a
click there which is different
for me because i think i've been talking
about it on the podcast a little bit and
bringing people on and talking to my mom
but nothing
clicked so it was really sudden click
and then
everything was great for about two weeks
so i was praying i was reading the bible
i was like this is fantastic
everything's working out and then two
weeks later i was like
just a little bit just this one little
thought that was like well you know
am i being silly there are actual like
more more logical explanations for why
things turned around
and that happened and then i had two
just miserable days
so it was like it was really it was just
two miserable days it was like what is
happening
why do i feel this like existential
horror again
uh which i would differentiate from
depression because i've been depressed
before this was really like existential
angst yeah um and so then i
i think
i
i
went back it's not like i'd stopped
reading the bible or stopped praying but
i was just a little bit more removed
from it and so
um
i i went back to it and then i had the
most wild dream so i was i was talking
to my parents about this and being like
i think i found god like
isn't that crazy
and
uh i went to sleep that night and i woke
up at 5 30 in the morning and i had a
dream
i think i can i think i'm allowed to
talk about this stuff but i had a dream
and this loud thundering voice just
yelled do it in the dream and i woke up
at 5 30 in the morning and was like i
think i just got yelled at by god i
think that just happened that's what it
felt like
what does that mean what does it mean so
i had kind of a rough morning i was like
i don't know what this means
is that really what happened um
and
and then it occurred to me that i think
what it meant was just go all in
don't do this like 75 in anyway so it's
been a wild month i'm doing really well
it's just i'm like i'm a little bit
shocked yeah i mean that that's
incredible
i would say there's a few things to
watch out for
as
you move through your path as a
christian
just know that there are going to be
many ups and downs and you mentioned
feeling a profound peace and
that's instructive because the world can
give you many things but it can't give
you peace
that kind of peace can only come from
god
and
it's important to remember however
that while i believe firmly that you're
going to be happier living a christian
lifestyle because you're going to be
doing the things god made you to do many
of the holiest saints
had very difficult lives and were very
miserable but there was a joy in their
misery
because they understood that this was
for something greater just the fact that
they were doing the will of god the fact
that it was god's will for them to be
miserable was enough for them to rejoice
in their own misery
and so we'll see that might take me a
little bit of time to get to it might
take me a little bit of time to get to
too it's tough it's tough and one thing
i have found
uh that
has helped me spiritually is like just
when you're suffering or when you're
miserable
thank god
for
letting you suffer thank god for showing
you that misery
because a it shows you how much you need
him
but be those closest to him will suffer
the most i mean look at his only
begotten son
um
so we should expect suffering as
christians and you know it's easy to
like when things are going well we want
to praise god and that's good because we
should um and when things are going
really bad it's also important to
remember that this is the author of all
things and the reason i'm going through
this is because
he wants it to make me better
and so i would just advise you that as
as you start to move through the
spiritual life and
things get really difficult thank him
thank him for the troubles because that
means
that means he's calling you to a real
relationship with him you know i mean
like he's calling you to a relationship
where you suffer for him which is what
love is fundamentally
and and that's not by the way the way i
worded that might have come off as if i
was suggesting you don't have real
relationship now that's not at all what
i'm saying
but
when he calls you
to that kind of suffering
it's to strengthen
your connection to him and your love for
him
okay
dad any comments are you just listening
well there's a
i hope i've got this right it's been a
long time since i thought about this but
and so apologies if i get it wrong but
when christ comes back
in revelation
he comes back as a judge
essentially and carl jung's comment on
that was
quite interesting is that the
christ presented in the gospels
the merciful element
is emphasized but
it's
both mercy and justice are
pinnacle moral principles and they're
opposed to one another to some degree
justice means the imposition of the
necessary rules and mercy means
forgiveness for
transgressing against them let's say and
so
you have to use mercy and justice
continually say when you're dealing with
children because you want them to
live according to a high moral standard
but of course they're going to fail and
so you have to forgive and so there's
this balance between mercy and
justice that seems necessary if you
forgive everything then
there are no standards by which to live
and if you impose the law
stringently to the letter
then everyone is
doomed because
everybody fails and so there's this
constant balance anyways jung said that
believed that
christ did the gospels
was primarily presented as a figure of
mercy and that needed
a balance to make the
image of perfection complete and so
the justice element
is emphasized in revelation
and one of the things christ says is
that
i know your works
that you were neither hot nor cold
i could wish that you were
cold or hot
um
and then it continues give me one more
second here
so because yeah well it's even more
it's it's more uh
what would you say direct than that
so because you are lukewarm
and neither hot nor cold i will spew the
out of my mouth
and the spew
it really means something like vomit
and it's it's it's a
an allusion to disgust
and so it's a very interesting idea is
that
the the people for whom the most severe
judgment is reserved yeah aren't the
committed sinners or the committed
saints they're the people in the middle
who sort of play both ends against the
middle who won't commit
and so
it's possible michaela that that
voice in your dream
this method of dream interpretation by
the way is called amplification and it's
a jungian technique and so
you know your
imagination
presented this to you as something akin
to a personal revelation
and so this is a
amplification with a more impersonal
revelation it's
don't play both ends against the middle
right commit
commit to what you're doing fully
and that's perhaps now i isn't clear
what that meant because the dream wasn't
that specific you have to work that out
for yourself
um
you know when you're doing something
halfway
well that's not
perhaps that's not for the best
so
it didn't even feel like halfway though
it felt like 75 or 80 at that point and
i think even that was that wasn't good
it was like a hundred or nothing exactly
that's what that felt like
you know christ didn't 80 die on the
cross for you know he went and did it
and we we have to love him he he did not
hedge his bets with us
i mean he
loves us so radically
that he gave his life up on the cross he
died on the cross for us
and for us to
see that and respond by saying let me
hedge my bets
is obviously unbelievably insulting
and so
i think it it makes sense for the
lukewarm to be spit out and that's sort
of how you could describe me because
like i said i was going to church at
this time
and
i
said i believe i mean i still identified
as catholic but again i remember telling
my brother at one point i was
functionally an atheist so
i was approached i was probably more
towards the cold end but i think
lukewarm
would be a fair description
this episode is brought to you by
blazing balls this is the best grill
i've found out there it heats up to 1500
degrees
so it only takes a few minutes to cook a
lamb or steak or if you're going to
tarnish it with a pizza
you can do that too morton's steakhouse
uses these guys they sell this grill to
other high-end restaurants but you can
do this at home chicken wings hamburgers
seafood vegetables pizza i guess steak
lamb whatever you can stick in a grill
you can use with this grill i love it my
dad has one they're super easy to use
portable and make delicious food they
gave me the code mp
for a hundred and fifty dollars off
their grills you can go to
blazingboldgrills.com code mp to check
them out they're made in america they're
a fantastic company this is hands down
the best at home grill i have ever seen
that's
blazingbullgrills.com code mp for 150
off check them out they're sponsoring my
episodes they're sponsoring dad their
girls are awesome i hope you enjoy the
rest of this episode
well i want to hear more about i know
i'm going to deflect the conversation to
some degree but i want to hear more
about the work that you're doing online
and and yeah and and your animation and
and what effect you've had that's had on
people and where what you're planning on
doing with that so who who all do you
imitate yeah
everybody so the thing with reuben is
my reuben impression is one of my most
popular but i don't think it's good um
the the video i did on him i wrote it as
a writing exercise because there were a
bunch of other impressions i wanted to
do and i was like well where would all
these people all these like conservative
or conservative adjacent or idw figures
who i was impersonating like where would
they be and like of course they would be
on dave rubin's shell so i just put him
there as a framing device and i don't
have any lines for him to say uh so i
just had him say i agree uh with
everything they said and i just the
reason he said that is because i think
he hits his g's kind of funny and i just
was the only thing i had for an
impression here you just go i agree with
that i agree and so he just does that
over and over
a while ago i recorded a video
it was actually about two years ago so i
did a video making fun of dave rubin um
and i went way harder on him than i
meant to
i really did not mean to be that mean
but people in the comments were like man
like you really got him and i was like
oh no like my goal was not to tear the
dude apart but he had a really good
sense of humor about it welcome to the
reuben report i'm your host dave rubin
the regressive left has abandoned
liberal values
the left is no longer liberal
they're regressive
the road to hell is paved with
regressive intentions
regressive regressive pc culture
regressive regressive left
today's non-regressive guest from the
non-regressive left here to talk about
the regressive pc leftist culture is
noted non-regressive
sam the non-regressive man harris how
does it feel to be non-regressive today
sam at the present moment uh the most
crucial point
for us to focus on is i agree
with that
uh you didn't let me finish regressive
i agree with that honestly dave if you
believe that you can just agree with
your guests on everything they say
you're totally i agree with that it's
like if you're not embodying the mythos
of the archetypal hero by metaphorically
dying you're never gonna kill the snake
man let alone rescue your father from
the underworld who has a billion of
anything nobody it's observed i
agree
with that i hope you're doing well dave
i
uh go
re
with that
okay so you're agreeing with me dave but
you haven't actually given me an
explanation for why you agree the
regressive left okay i'm sorry to
interrupt but uh dave how attractive was
your single mother
did she leave your daycare
i
agree
anita sarkeesian spent 17 billion
dollars on a 30-second video where she
says the word feminism four times
after promising her donor she could get
the video done in i
agree
with that honestly gang i knew this was
happening he was agreeing with all of us
this is clearly not uh
an honest person that we're dealing with
i view him truly as a bad actor well
that depends on what your definition of
truth is sam oh not this again so
i'm not the only one he agrees with okay
folks clearly as i've mentioned he's
been agreeing with all of us on
everything when he should only be
agreeing with me on everything okay
if you think if you think we're ever
going to be doing your shell again after
this you are sorely mistaken buster
brown my gosh
what you have done here today cuts to
the depth of my soul and strips me of my
faith in human virtue i may have brought
humanity a thousand years forward in
mortal philosophy but you've set it back
two thousand i can't think of anyone
more likely to have been spanked as a
child good luck finding new people to
interview you eatable tyrants
and he brought me uh like a year
i think two years ago maybe three years
ago now i was out in la
and we recorded a sequel video to it
which we still have not finished a
release um but in the sequel video i had
to do my impression of dave ruben to
dave rubin's face and it was like a
really mean impression i was like this
is
this is like i was like i deserve this i
100 deserve this i take no joy in it um
so as for my work you are asking which
video is the most popular
um i think
the most popular is fighting nazis then
verse now
i can double check on that
but the basic idea behind that video was
you had all these lefties going around
saying right-wingers are all nazis
and calling them nazis for things which
my grandfather uh who fought in the
second world war
believed
and there are some things where you can
argue okay
when it comes to some of the people get
labeled nazis like if they're
you know if they're into racial politics
uh in that way or they're
you know white nationals then you sort
of sort of understand the comparisons
but often people will get called nazis
for things like
being against abortion or against gay
marriage or believing in two genders i
mean for goodness sake
dr peterson has been called one i'm sure
i've been called one like these are just
this is just a term people throw around
i haven't yet
you haven't yet no i don't know if i
have to be honest but i i know that once
as soon as you're but that just means
i'm not influential enough right like
once you have a large enough platform
that's just the mean that's just the
swear word people have for you
so
i just wanted to do this video because i
was like my grandfather and all the guys
he fought alongside
would be appalled by your lifestyle you
know choices and like the idea that you
would call them a nazi for that was
hilarious so i just thought it'd be
funny to do a cartoon where a bunch of
lefties build a time machine
and bring these world war ii veterans
out of the war and into their own time
and tell them nazis have invaded america
look what they're doing uh and then they
start describing all the things that the
nazis are doing and the soldiers are
like
that just makes it it's actually i'm not
sure how much of it it would make sense
for me to spoil here but
the um
one of the first jokes is
they give them like a donald trump
pamphlet on his positions and one of the
soldiers goes this guy's disgusting this
guy thinks two men can get married um
and the the laughter's like no no that's
not what's wrong with him but like
realistically if you're gonna try to
compare yourself to the people who
fought in world war ii you should expect
more conservative leading social values
so okay folks so as you know nazism is
on the rise and we need to stop them
which is why i've invented a time
machine to bring back the people who
defeated nazism in the first place
perfect yes
hey this ain't normandy what girls what
year is it it's 2018
why did you say that so weird uh sorry
fourth of habit we brought you to the
future because nazism is on the rise in
the u.s and our president is sympathetic
to them what here's a pamphlet with all
his positions
ah this fella's disgusting right this
boyfriend thinks two men can get married
what and that a man who cuts his dongle
off is a woman um sounds more like a
comedy to me but hey same difference
i'll kill either one uh that's not
what's bad about him it gets weiss what
else are these nazis doing they believe
there are only two genders well of
course there's more than two genders
thank goodness yeah the russians have
their gender the germans have their
gender the japanese have their gender
everybody's gotten a gender no not
agenda gender what the hell is gender
sounds like some kind of phony word
popularized in the 50s to create a false
distinction between one identity and
their biological sex am i in a ballpark
here your sex is whether you're male or
female but your gender is how you
identify so if you were born a man but
want to become a woman your gender
identity is as a woman and you therefore
are a woman you know what so you guys
think men can be women well that's the
biggest kraken nonsense i ever heard
yeah none of this sounds like nazism to
me well how about this he wants people
to pay for their own birth control oh no
yeah birth control is legal
the guys who defeated nazism are such
nazis you know i don't like you pinkos
going around telling people you're
fighting nazis just because you berate
everyone you disagree with you've never
fought a nazi in your life and to claim
otherwise is stolen valor yeah and you
know what when actual nazis come around
no one's gonna want to fight him anymore
cause you guys keep crying wolf now
let's go back and win ourselves a war
you know i almost don't want to anymore
wait
don't go
we need you we need to say you're on our
side so we can convince the greater
whole of society to accept violence
against dissidents who stand in the way
of the social order we seek to establish
ah
and how exactly are they the nazis
because i call them nazis well you call
men women so
and i struck a nerf because it racked up
i think like two and a half million
views
and then the other one that was popular
was just me making fun of ben shapiro um
so you've supported like
this really racist idea
that healthcare
should not be for free
and i just wanted to ask about that okay
so here's how this works gang honestly
if you can't see that a universal health
care system is bad for america you're
wasting my time okay okay folks so the
health care cost crisis didn't actually
begin until the government got involved
by creating medicare and medicaid
because when you artificially stimulate
demand there's no incentive to lower
price not to mention you are not
entitled to the product of somebody
else's labor that's called slavery gang
okay this is what would actually happen
under a universal health care system
here's what a single-payer healthcare
system would actually do okay folks it
would actually make doctors literal
slaves who would have to live in cabins
on a plantation somewhere all right
folks
and the idea and the idea that doctors
are just your slaves who can you can you
know marry without their consent and
then make half doctor have regular
people babies with okay well then what
happens to the babies are are they now
doctors are they slave doctors who have
to be doctors or are they free like now
what king okay so that's why that system
would just never work but
but but i should just get health care
i should just get it for free
and that's how you talk to a leftist
[Music]
how does ben shapiro feel about that
he's been very cool he's been very cool
about it so later on he did a video
he did a video reviewing
my video
and then
i did a video of cartoon him reviewing
the video of him reviewing my video
so we just got a couple layers deep with
it
but he was very cool he was watching the
video he was laughing it's like hanging
honestly i'm gonna be really freedom is
actually fantastic uh outlet and they
make very funny cartoons you should go
check them out go to freedivingpins.com
right now okay fox they're fantastic go
subscribe youtube.com freedom channels
these are fantastic guys i love them uh
he's super cool about it super cool i've
never met him but every time he's
encountered my work he's had a good
sense of hearing about it he's shared it
he's praised it so he's been he's been
very cool i've met him and that sounded
quite a bit like him
honestly if we cover the camera maybe
we'll we'll say he's here yeah that was
that was uh quite interesting hearing
that coming out of your mouth
thank you thank you yeah
i'll take it as a compliment
i will add a couple of clips into the
podcast so that people can see what
we're talking about i like the
thanksgiving dinner one happy
thanksgiving
thanksgiving
thanksgiving okay folks who made these
cranberries honestly these are the worst
cranberries i've ever tasted i made them
and it's actually extremely impolite for
you to insult my cooking on thanksgiving
okay folks our taste buds don't care
about your feelings okay okay gang well
if you want to make your own cranberries
feel free but you're not entitled to
free food and the idea that you would
complain over quality of service when
you're receiving it for free is just
ridiculous okay okay can somebody please
pass the mashed potatoes folks auntie
these are my mashed potatoes okay i made
them myself and they're there for the
product of my own labor and the idea and
the idea and the idea that you feel it's
acceptable to put a gun to my head and
force me not only to give you the mashed
potatoes but to actually have me pass
them to you as well is absolutely
asinine okay okay well that would be a
solid argument if not for the fact that
you're eating asparagus which i made
okay ben how could you seriously not
pass the mashed potatoes after taking
her asparagus is it my fault she gave it
away for free and lost all leverage i'm
trying to teach my child how to compete
and succeed within the free market okay
folks good good guy got folks i didn't
realize i was surrounded by communists i
have the mashed potatoes and asparagus
because i make good decisions okay folks
honestly man you're the last person to
get smart with me considering you're the
only one in the family to be born with
an iq lower than 300. okay well you know
what auntie believe it or not some
people consider an iq of 215 to be
relatively impressive all right folks
sorry i'm late folks i had more
important things to take care of i'm
actually a doctor she's a doctor folks
life's a doctor she's a doctor my wife's
a doctor did you bring the turkey
gobble gobble socialism works
that one was a lot of fun to make uh it
was actually i think it was a friend who
originally suggested that they're like
you should do
something where like it's just everyone
is him
and
i was so irresistible
and that i had to and i did it and
shapiro tweeted it like the day i
uploaded it shapiro said this is a
documentary and tweeted it i tweeted
that out
um
so he's very cool about it and
yeah i think
i've mentioned this before the work has
changed a bit over the years it started
i started again as like a hardcore
libertarian and i was making stuff that
i thought was funny and
was promoting my values but i think i
put much more emphasis on like this has
to be an educational thing and we still
do educational cartoons
i was doing like a lot of research last
week on some really dark stuff for a
couple videos
but
over time it's changed and i think over
time it's also become more informed by
my faith
and i also think it's become funnier i
think i
probably like the last year or two i've
more found my voice as a cartoon writer
and i've gotten more comfortable just
like getting really zany and crazy with
it so i'm i'm really happy with like
where we're at in the direction we're
taking it in and i have to say i have
some like fantastic
people helping me with these the like
the fact that my team like it's
something that's not obvious to people
who aren't animators but
getting a video done per week sometimes
two done per week while also like
managing other client work like the fact
that my team is able to do that i say
this completely unironically i think i
actually have the best team of low
budget animators probably in the world
like it's it's unbelievable
um
what
we've been able to achieve together and
a lot of that is just because i can
depend on them and they're all very
talented so it started with just me
animating this stuff by myself and like
maybe my one of my buddies
um would help with like lip syncing and
stuff but now it's it's probably over
the past like this last year is when
i've
gotten a lot more people on board um and
it's yeah no it's it's it's been like i
said a huge blessing and by the way are
you wearing white after labor day i just
realized i can't
is that like there are a lot of wrote
like catholics with their rules that's
not like it's not for vestments
what's wrong with what
it's a joke it's like is that an
american thing i've just heard people
it's an american thing yeah
what is it
people say you can't wear white after
labor no one it's a weird thing that
people say but that like no one does
it's not an actual rule it's just
literally just the thing people say and
it's just the day after
i think it's in general
but then it's like every it's always
after labor day technically
so
yes i'm wearing white after labor day no
i don't know what that means or
represents the significance to your
rebelling
okay
are we doing the jordan peterson like
the really the reason i wanted to talk
to you was for the imitation
i i said it was all i'm good for but
it's really i'm just waiting for the jbp
imitation hold on a second as
uncomfortable as humanly possible
i appreciate that you know
comfort comfort can kill the soul and
suffering is good for you i think it's
right we're not called
we're we're not called to comfort we're
called to greatness as benedict xvi said
when he was rating her um
man
this is a tough one so this is no more
questions about my work you're just
going to launch into my impression
okay
well
someone in the comments
asked and i saw you put that tweet out
what questions should i ask him
and one of the comments
was to ask me to review shrek 2
as jordan peterson yes okay
fantastic question
all right i didn't know i was gonna have
to do it in front of him hoping i could
hide here but we'll do it
we'll do it we'll give it a go you know
it's like what is shrek and that's
that's a pretty straightforward question
like he's an ogre he lives in a swamp he
doesn't have any friends so he's he's
not much different from you roughly
speaking and
in shrek 2 which is a very old story
he has to go off to far far away to meet
his new in-laws it's like you may think
meeting in-laws is a cakewalk man but it
is not especially if you're an ogre and
so what does shrek do well he brings his
friend donkey and why is that
why is it that he's always hanging
around with a donkey well because when
you're an ogre who spends all of your
time in the swamp your only friend is
going to be an ass
when they went to far far away
shrek discovered through his adventures
that unlike in the first film sometimes
when people reject him it's his own
fault
and that if you really try
and you really work at yourself just for
a moment you can go from an ogre to a
prince
hey that was pretty good and right down
the spot there too
thank you
yeah well it's a very strange experience
to hear my voice coming out of someone
else's mouth
i have a bit of an irish accent in your
version of me is that oh no that means
i'm doing the canadian accent poorly
well maybe not maybe maybe that's just
an element of it that i can't hear but
yeah exactly
i want to hear more of these i
definitely impersonate some other
figures it's it can be hard for me to
think off the top of my head some other
internet people politicians if you just
want to like throw some my way i'll let
you know trump
trump
okay first of all
some people are saying
that i didn't invent the masks first of
all i invented the mask and frankly some
of you would look much better at a mask
wouldn't something i think nancy pelosi
would look much better in a mask don't
you think she'd look much better to mask
fox and then everyone in the audience
applauds and loses their mind she would
look much better at a mask
[Laughter]
uh i maybe i need a different job here's
the thing michaela
yeah the real difficult day
that's gonna be when i have to do my
trump impression in front of trump if
that ever happens because that's it
that's it yeah
he'll destroy me he'll be like sleepy
sheamus
makes his stupid cartoons making fun of
me because i'm successful and he's
just he'll rip me apart
okay thank you you're welcome we can
like that i mean we can end the podcast
now realistically i mean if look if you
want to get away from me i understand
that's what i wanted out of this podcast
uh dad
dad do you have more questions i was
just going to ask what sort of impact
sheamus thinks his cartoons have had on
people i i
what what function have you served as
far as you can tell
that's a good question so
i think that i have
and it depends on the kind of stuff
we're talking about like the freedom
tune stuff specifically
i think i've
helped people to know more so than
anything else that they're not insane
um that there are other people who feel
this way
and see the world for what it is rather
than what they're told to believe by the
dominant media culture and that
it's it's okay to laugh at some of this
stuff and you kind of have to
um and i think i've also done like i've
educated uh
a good amount we we've done a number of
educational videos talking about uh you
know planned parenthood and a lot of the
myths they propagate and debunking
things like that so i think that
contribution has been good as well most
recently i think what we've done is just
make people laugh over things that would
normally make them cry and maybe give
them a break from the unbridled
punishment that paying attention to
politics is
no more questions on my end
well thank you so much thank you so much
this has been fantastic
that was really interesting yeah and
thank you dad pleasure meeting you it
was a pleasure meeting you as well it
was a pleasure meeting you and i might i
may have to ask for a cameo from you at
some point in the future
that can likely be arranged yes for the
freedom tunes channel
we'll see yes
done um where can people find you if
they're not familiar with your work
that's a good question so youtube.com
and that's t o o and s
o o n s like cartoons some people i see
it's spelled like musical cartoons oons
um so youtube.com freedomtunes
and i'm on twitter at sheamus underscore
coughlin which is really easy to spell
so people will
figure that out
um if you just want to like put a link
to that in the description that would
probably i will do that be better famous
coughlin yeah wow that you must have had
a rough time growing up you know what i
did i did it but it shaped me into the
man that i am today and
i also regularly do tim pool's podcast
um tim cast irl so i i'm on there quite
a bit as well um i have another channel
i have this channel called politivlog
that i don't upload too often enough
it's probably been like a year and so my
fans get very angry but if you kind of
want to see what few videos there are of
me a pining not being animated um then
check that out too
okay but freedom tunes is the main one
yeah well thank you very much for coming
on that was fun
thank you i had a blast
thank you
[Music]
you